let me bring in florida governor ron
desantis now get some reaction to what
we just heard
governor thanks very much for being here
and standing by throughout our live
coverage of the g7
closeout meeting your reaction to what
you heard from the president
well maria i think it's quite a contrast
from uh his predecessor i think that
president biden is someone that's uh
much more passive on the world stage
uh not nearly as assertive as somebody
like donald trump was
um i think his his energy level is
obviously much lower
and so i think that's just something
that people are sizing up i think that
our adversaries are watching that
i didn't hear very much in the way of
holding china accountable
for their role in covering up the
origins of the covid19 pandemic
i think that's absolutely essential that
china be held accountable for their role
in that as well as any bureaucrats in
the united states who may have been
covering up but you know they were
talking economically a lot about
other countries he was talking about uh
reducing energy production worldwide
and i couldn't help but think you know
here in the united states you know he's
leaving a lot of people behind look at
all the workers he left behind by
canceling the keystone xl pipeline those
were thousands
and thousands of very good jobs and then
also think about
family budgets with the sharp increase
in gas prices
and then the overall budding inflation
that we're seeing that's being fueled by
this big spending policy so
i think that his performance probably
played well uh with european elites
uh not sure that uh there was much in it
for middle america
yeah we will hear more about his plans
for taxes he wants to have
a global minimum tax of 15
in some economies that would actually be
a tax increase
if you look at a place like ireland so
we'll get more on that but
one uh study struck me before i was
coming on the air with you and this was
about florida
and it says the average taxpayer who
moved to florida
from the other 49 states had an average
income
this is an average gross income of a
hundred and ten thousand dollars which
is about twice the average household
income
of course you don't have income tax in
florida and it's actually
helped your economy tell us uh assess
the economy right now
in florida and tell us what you've seen
over the last year in terms of
an increase in population
well sure marie i mean before covid we
had seen by far
the highest amount of wealth move into
florida compared to any other state but
i think that's accelerated
uh since covid i think you're seeing a
lot of people
move here obviously we have a very
favorable tax climate florida's the
lowest per capita tax burden
individual tax burden in the country and
we're very proud of that that has led
obviously to more
businesses moving here so we've got a
lot of great things
i think on the horizon but it's a lesson
in how you do this
you tax people you attack business you
do all those things
in a country like ours it's very mobile
people vote with their feet
and so what we've been able to do is
with low taxes and a favorable
environment
we end up taking in more revenue than we
probably would if we had higher taxes
because
of the underlying dynamism of the
economy
yeah it's incredible you've been doing
so much governor i want to get into some
of your moves and
let me start with the bill that you just
signed to stop the censorship
of floridians last week on this program
we went through the fouchy facebook
files
where it's clear based on emails between
mark zuckerberg and dr anthony
fauci they were coordinating in terms of
what should be uh
reported on facebook and what shouldn't
be facebook took down many posts
about the origins of covet 19 only to
have egg on its face
when they had to change the policy again
do you believe
fauci colluded with mark zuckerberg does
this expose
facebook to legal action which of course
is what senator ted cruz told us
last week well you pointed out something
important maria what they censored was
actually true
they called it a conspiracy theory if
you said this may have leaked from the
lab
they were also censoring around the same
time last year any criticisms of
lockdowns and we know now lockdowns
didn't work states like florida that
were open
were better off for it and so you often
hear people say hey these are private
companies they can do what they want
yada yada yada but here's an example of
working with fauci
where facebook you could argue is
essentially acting as an arm of the
state
because there's they're suppressing what
the government once suppressed
and so i think this issue with big tech
is unlike anything we've seen
they have massive amounts of power these
are monopolies that are
much stronger than the monopolies of the
early 20th century
they control in effect a handful of
companies a huge percentage of the
political speech in this country
and so i think when you have situations
they're not just
censoring based on partisanship
obviously we've seen conservatives be
censored
but when they're censoring things about
some of the most important
issues that we've ever addressed how
coveted started whether lockdowns work
you know they're really doing damage to
society
yeah they've suddenly believed come to
believe that they are the arbiters of
truth and
many of the things that they're
censoring uh are in fact
true as you say is florida considering
uh
is florida considering legal actions
against facebook
well i i know that the state's already
involved in some of the the
multi-state litigation that predated
those revelations
i mean obviously i would support any
ways that we can vindicate
the rights of individual floridians to
be able to converse about public
issues now our bill is the first of its
kind it really tracks what justice
clarence thomas laid out
in his ca one of his concurrences a few
months ago where
these companies really are more akin to
common carriers
and so they should be treated as such
you know and our view is
is yes you can have certain obviously
guidelines or however you do it
but you got to apply it evenly and if
you don't you're advertising as an open
platform
you're saying you're not publishers but
then you're acting as publishers by
stifling
speech you don't like that's a fraud on
the consumer and people deserve to be
able to vindicate their rights in court
i mean this censorship feels like
communist china
you know you've talked about big tech
and its relationship to the chinese
communist party
you've been researching this you say
that the lockdown approach
that was led by the democrats was
promoted by the ccp
tell me about that sure
before i do just point out when we
signed the big tech bill
i had folks who had fled communist cuba
speaking about how important it was
i had people that have fled socialist
venezuela
talking about how important it was to
combat censorship because they lived
through really bad periods of censorship
you look at how big tech has handled the
ccp
they are very deferential uh to the
communist party of china
and i think that china was very much
invested
in promoting lockdowns as we started
getting in
to 2020 february march obviously italy
those italy lockdowns
were very much patterned off what we saw
in wuhan
and facebook and some of these big
companies
they were really serving to elevate the
lockdown hysteria
and to absolutely suppress people who
are raising questions and concerns about
lockdowns and
the reason why that's so i think so
galling is because
up until kovid public health guidance
was never
in a pandemic to just lock down
indefinitely this was kind of a new
invention
that was really fueled by the chinese
experience and so
i think the relationship between big
tech and the ccp
is very problematic and quite frankly a
lot of these big corporations
particularly in entertainment and some
of these other uh fields
of the american economy and i wonder if
it starts with academia governor
you know you heard president biden say
that he wants more transparency
from china but we really haven't seen a
tough stance in terms of u.s policy
on china in fact just this week
president biden revoked
president trump's ban on tick tock and
on wechat
i know that you have talked about the
ccp infiltrating
florida universities you've got
confucius centers
this is a very important point and i
want you to talk about
what you're doing these two bills that
you just signed
in terms of stopping the influence
foreign influence in universities
because
the ccp has been able to get inside
of important institutions in this
country
and steal data we know that secretary
pompeo has said
they are now inside the gates there was
a string of
indictments in 2020 by the pompeo state
department
everyone from a you know the head of the
biology department at harvard to
an nypd officer to shutting down the
embassy in houston
they do get inside of our institutions
what can you do to stop it
and tell me about those confucius
centers in florida
so we did two bills one uh to combat
foreign influence specifically targeted
at the ccp
as well as corporate espionage which
also is generally targeted at the ccp
because they're the worst offenders
so we actually had a confucius institute
that was done at miami-dade college
fortunately when i became governor we
looked at that and and we we had the
college get rid of it however
this is something i think that's going
to be a continued concern so our bill we
sign
basically bans things like confucius
institutes
from getting a foothold uh on florida
universities and i think that's really
important but as you document
there it seems like every other week
there'll be some academic researcher
who's identified as having ties with the
ccp
people get indicted people flee america
once there once they're found out about
this
and so we're really trying to scrutinize
what's going on in these universities
inside florida we also want to protect
trade secrets from our businesses and
all that
because ccp infiltration there has been
very very prominent throughout the
country
but man these academia there's deep ties
in many segments of academia with the
communist party of china
i want you to hear president biden talk
about xi jinping recently
i was astounded at these comments and
again we still
do not have a clear understanding of
what biden's policy
is on china here he is just a few weeks
ago watch this governor
i've spent more time with president xi
of china
than any world leader has for 24 hours
of private meetings with him
a just interpreter 17 000 miles
traveling
in china and here he firmly believes
that china before the year 3035 is going
to own america
because autocracies can make quick
decisions
but america is unique
of all nations in the world
we're the only nation organized based on
an idea
so that's it governor the xi jinping for
the president of china thinks he's going
to own america within 15 years
that's what you just heard from
president biden
yeah i mean it's really astounding um
but i tell you this
origins of covid this is such an
astounding cover-up one of the biggest
cover-ups
we've ever seen probably in the history
of our country that we've dealt with in
terms of what they did
with the gain of function research
understanding that these researchers had
been infected
uh in the fall of 2019 and then to cover
it up for months
and then to not be view that as
something that's of utmost importance
to be able to one get the truth but then
to hold china accountable
they caused immense damage throughout
the world
by allowing this uh this virus to be
unleashed
on the rest of the world and so to be
that deferential to china
i don't think that's what the american
public is looking for
i think that they want to see a policy
from the united states that's more
assertive
against china that understands china is
a threat they're an economic competitor
but they're also
a threat in terms of what they're trying
to achieve militarily
governor real quick before we go set the
record straight on the cruise industry i
know that there is a narrative being
pushed by the media right now that
you're in a war with the cruise industry
over whether or not to require vaccine
passports where
are you with the cruise industry and
what should americans expect
well we're in a fight with the cdc who's
mothballed the industry for over a year
we don't believe they have the authority
to do that we're suing them in federal
court
we just had a hearing last week very
positive response we thought
from the court we think we'll get a
favorable ruling there we definitely
think we would win on appeal as well
and so once we're past the cdc's
intransigence
then they're going to be free to sail in
florida they of course are going to have
to fall
follow florida law but you know they're
going to be able to do it
without requiring vaccine passports you
know the cdc maria
they don't recognize immunity conferred
through infection and we know there have
been tens of millions of people
who have immunity through that way why
would you say they can't participate
in society why do we want people to be
divulging all this health information
and so we have a blanket ban on that
across the state of florida
but we also believe that once cdc
gets out of the way that you're going to
see cruz's resume in florida very soon
governor real quick before you go you've
been showing real leadership
in a very difficult time have you had
serious discussions with president trump
about partnering with him
for 2024 and iran
no and i haven't had any discussions
with anybody about anything beyond what
we're doing now because you know we're
putting a lot of points on the board
we're really
going on offense moving the ball forward
i got a great state a big state
we've got a lot on our plate here and so
we take it one day at a time and try to
achieve things for the people of florida
governor you're doing a great job we
appreciate your time this morning thank
you sir
we will see you soon thank you florida
governor
ron desantis